[Music]
welcome to the science podcast for
February 16 2018 I'm Sara Krusty in this
week's show David Grimm talks about
genes that turn on after death and what
we can learn from their activity and
David John's talks about the so called
sugar conspiracy and how it doesn't
quite hold up to a close examination of
the history of nutrition policy in the
US now we have David Grimm editor for
our daily news site he's here to talk
about what happens to us after we die
welcome Dave hey Sara okay so finally we
know what happens after we die well we
know what happens to our genes okay so
this is about what genes do when we're
no longer alive the researchers in this
case we're looking at gene regulation in
different tissues living tissue dead
tissue preserved tissue why were they
doing that in the first place well you
know they're part of this study this
called this it's called a genotype
tissue expression pilot which is a large
consortium of geneticists and Melchor
biologists they've been measuring Veen
activity in tissues from hundreds of
people and the goal of this project is
determined how the body makes different
cells do different things so they're
really this had nothing to do with death
but as part of the project tissues are
preserved and the researchers know how
long those tissues you know when the
person who donated this tissues died
between when they died and when this
issue's actually went into formaldehyde
so they have these windows of time where
they can say I wondered what's happening
to some of these genes after a person
dies and what can this actually tell us
and this isn't the first time anyone's
discovered you know checked out whether
or not genes are still doing something
after death there was an earlier study
that showed that this went on for a
surprisingly long amount of time right
right yeah this was a study that we
talked about last year it wasn't done in
humans it was done in deceased mice and
zebrafish but the researchers kind of
this creepy say the researchers found
that even four days after death some
genes remain active in some cases even
ramping up genes potentially involved in
things like cancer promotion and
development which was kind of creepy but
this new study is all dealing with human
genes human tissues what patterns did
they pick out here when it came to
undead gene
in people well they found it was really
organ specific so for example there was
very little change in gene activity over
time in the brain or the spleen or at
least issues that came from there but
more than 600 muscle genes either
quickly increased or decreased their
activity after somebody died which is
really interesting the researchers also
discovered that for example in blood
decreased activity and genes involved in
DNA production and the immune response
but an increase in those genes involved
with stress response signal that a
person had died about six hours before
preservation and that brings in this
time element so you can look across
tissues or across different genes and
then be able to point backwards at when
the death happens well that's the idea
so this is still a very preliminary
state right now they're trying to get a
sense of what genes are turning on which
genes are turning off what does that
tell us about the timing and then the
idea is to put that all together and say
you know can we come up with a computer
program where we could just refuse into
it and it could tell us precisely when
somebody died what about how they died
well that's the other idea because what
the researchers found also is that the
changes in gene expression may actually
carry a signature of the cause of death
so you can imagine a future detective
not having to do as much guesswork it
actually just being able to sort of feed
some of the stuff into a computer and
figure out not only when somebody died
but maybe what killed them in the first
place Wow one thing I wanted to ask
before I wrap up David is what are these
genes doing what possible reason could
there be for a gene to turn on and
become active after death well you know
at least in the previous study when we
have this thing were developmental genes
we're turning on during death the idea
was well perhaps the conditions are
similar in a dying body to those in
embryo but we don't really know why all
these genes are turning on enough but
the question is can we actually harvest
usable information from it alright okay
what else is on the site this week Dave
well Sarah we've got a couple cool
videos for you which I'm sure you know
all about one about robots modeled on
cockroaches that crash into walls why
are they crashing the wall so you'll
have to read the story to find out also
a story and video about ants healing
each other from injuries on the
battlefield why they do that for science
etc policy blog we've got a very
in-depth analysis of US President Trump
proposed 2019 budget what the impact on
various science agencies would be also a
story about whether peer reviews from
journal articles should be published
alongside with the journal article as
well and finally Sarah both you and I
will be at the annual triple-a s meeting
yeah this coming week in Austin Texas
and will be hopefully doing a lot of
cool stories from the meeting and
talking about those on the podcast as
well all right thanks Dave thanks Sarah
you can check out the latest news in the
policy blog science insider at News
Science back org be sure to stay tuned
for an interview with David John's about
the so called
sugar conspiracy the idea that
information about sugars harms were
covered up by the industry this week in
science David Jones and Gerald
Oppenheimer write about this conspiracy
to create a sugar conspiracy or at least
to paint a change in dietary advice from
the 50 60s and 70s from non-fat to low
sugar as a conspiracy perpetuated by the
sugar industry ok David what drew your
attention to this topic how did you get
involved in writing about the sugar
conspiracy so I had been conducting
research in Harvard's
medical archives in the papers of Mark
Haig stead for a completely different
different reason and it's been something
like a month sifting through this
gentleman's papers when this story about
the sugar industry having influenced
mark hex Ted in particular got a lot of
media attention and I just felt that the
way that he was being represented in
some of these stories did not reflect
the person whose papers I had been
reading who seemed to be a serious
scientist who certainly did work with
industry but who believed that dietary
fat was harmful you know before he was
purportedly contracted by the sugar
industry he was known as an unusually
scrupulous scientist as a really
data-driven person who was actually sort
of weirdly honest in a way ok well let's
talk about what was going on in the
media like what were people saying what
are they what is this sugar conspiracy
that we talked about in the title of the
piece so the idea basically was that
somehow the sugar industry had quote
shifted the blame to fat
the sugar industry by paying certain
researchers including this guy mark hex
Ted had sort of pushed Dietary research
and policy in a new direction that would
sort of downplay the focus on sugar and
increase the focus on fat or allow the
fad theory to rise and when you say the
fad theory and the sugar theory you're
talking about whether or not it's linked
with heart disease mortality and stuff
like that that's right with heart
disease in particular at that time was
the major focus so the idea being that
cheeseburgers might give you a heart
attack I mean that was sort of a very
kind of simplistic way of putting one of
the ways of thinking that people had
about dietary fat specifically saturated
fat and that these fats would cause the
coronary arteries to become blocked up
and that you might have a heart attack
or have heart problems so as a
consequence of a lot of this research
and you know this opinion that was being
released back in the 50s and 60s we
ended up with the no fat low fat diet
fat in the 80s and 90s that's right I
mean it's sort of generally referred to
as a low fat diet I mean the truth is
that the recommendations that came out
had a broad range of things that they
recommended they did recommend big
reductions in sugar intake they
recommended consuming more fruits and
vegetables they recommended consuming
more whole grains and complex
carbohydrates some of the things we
actually think are still good ideas now
but there was a big emphasis on dietary
fat and it was something that people
talked about a lot and it was something
that some very prominent nutrition
researchers really emphasized and they
thought was really the most important
thing that that needed to happen for
Public Health going back to the history
part of it what you know you actually
say no this didn't happen or this didn't
happen like this or this was normal for
the time can you talk a little bit about
some of the history that people are
pointing at and saying that's when the
conspiracy happened that's who was
involved and and what your understanding
of what actually happened is so there
were people in the 1960s we focus on
British researcher named John Yadkin who
was interested in the idea that sugar
might contribute to heart disease there
was a whole nother group who felt that
as we've discussed dietary fat was more
likely the culprit in in heart disease
and there was a sort of a disagreement a
bit between these groups now
disagreements and science are common and
disagreement sometimes
took a heated form but the general claim
has been that somehow the sugar
hypothesis was not given appropriate
attention was not considered in in a
serious way because the sugar industry
intervened and that this somehow shaped
the course of dietary policy it shifted
the blame to dietary fat that you know
that this was a pivot point in history
and things could have gone one direction
or they could have gone another
direction but they went in the direction
of fad in part because of the
interventions of the sugar industry and
your research shows that that's probably
not what happened yeah our research
shows that the researcher who mark
hagstead who was stood sort of accused
of having been sort of an co-opted by
the sugar industry actually believed the
things that he he the sugar industry
paid him in effect to amplify beliefs he
already had so our research kind of puts
the agency back in the hands of
scientists in a way and suggests that
the claims that the industry was really
behind the course of dietary science and
policy may be overstated
right okay so we kind of have these two
teams team sugar tuna pad and you know
over time the industries were involved
in research on both sides researchers
were involved in you know all kinds of
science here and now today you know
people have backed off the low-fat diet
sugar and high carbohydrates are
considered somewhat dangerous but do we
know right now the linkages are we sure
today about the relationship between fat
sugar carbohydrates and heart disease so
I'm a historian I'm not a scientist but
you know there are plenty of people who
will tell you what the science says
there's no question there's been a shift
in emphasis from dietary fat to sugar
and carbohydrates in general I would say
but I think there's still a view that
saturated fat is harmful and there is
still a question of whether sugar per se
has special harms associated with it
apart from its caloric content in other
words that there's something
specifically toxic or poisonous or doula
tereus about sugar per se that goes
beyond its caloric contribution to the
diet I kind of want to circle back to
what we talked about at the beginning
there's been the
talk in the media about a conspiracy
relating to big sugar what do you think
is the biggest problem with placing a
conspiracy narrative on something that
happened that looks like it was more
just a natural product of science over
time changing what was considered
important or changing the way analysis
was done I think you put you put your
finger on a big piece of it right there
which is that you know science is not a
train running down the track where it
goes in one direction science you know
has many twists and turns and sometimes
it takes moves into a call to sack or
takes the wrong path and sometimes it
you know reverses course
so there's many twists and turns and so
to interpret the twists and turns as the
product of kind of dark forces or you
know industry interventions in the
absence of very strong evidence you know
there's no question that industries have
tried to manipulate science and have you
know often succeeded or sometimes
succeeded in the case of tobacco and and
and lead but we we think that to look
back at the history of science and
without strong evidence and say that
there was an industry intervention that
caused it to do one thing versus the
other is dangerous to our understanding
of how science actually works right ok
David thank you so much for talking with
me thank you so much Sarah David John's
and Gerald Oppenheimer write about the
sugar conspiracy this week in science
you can find a link to their article at
science mag - podcasts and that
concludes this edition of the science
podcast if you have any comments or
suggestions for the show write to us at
science podcast at AAAS dot RG you can
subscribe to the show at itunes stitcher
and many other places or listen to us on
the Science site at science magnet or
expose where you can also find links to
the articles discussed in the episode
this show was produced by Sarah crusty
and edited by Paula G Jeffrey cook
composed the music on behalf of science
magazine and its publisher triple-a us
thanks for joining us
you
[Music]